Hi there everyone and a very warm
welcome back to the channel. In today's
video, we're going to be testing a bunch
of ESC's from T- Motor, Boret, and
Newbie Drone. Looking at acceleration,
deceleration, torque, efficiency, and
for the first time, thermal performance
to see which of these ESC's you should
pick and which you should definitely
avoid. It's a lot to cover in one video,
so let's not waste any more time. Let's
dive right into it. In this video, we're
going to be looking at four different
ESC's from T- Hobby, formerly T- Motor,
the Veloc 50 amp and 70 amp ESC's. The
F55 Amp Pro 3 and the Pacer P60 amp V2.
We've also got two ESC's from ZDX
Future, the Boret 80 Amp and 80 Amp
Mini, and two ESC's from Newbie Drone,
the Hummingbird 305 and the Hummingbird
200 Race Spec. If you're excited for
these test results, please remember to
like, subscribe, and leave a comment
down below. Let me know what ESC you'd
like to see tested in the next batch or
what new tests I could add. And if
you're an ESC manufacturer, drop me an
email, chrisac.com,
so you don't miss out being included in
future testing. Before we dive into the
results, let me take you through the
test setup and test methodology that
we're going to be using to capture this
data. All of the tests are going to be
run using the Titto Robotics Flight
Stand 15 Pro. And this is a big upgrade
on my previous test setup because it
samples over 10 times faster up to a
thousand hertz. So we can see much
faster changes in the motor RPM and ESC
currents. It also supports much higher
current draws up to 150 amps. And it's
got an ASM calibrated load cell so we
can ensure that all of the results are
super accurate. I'm going to be using
the Thermal Master P3 thermal camera to
record the temperature of all the ESC's
during the test. And as we draw more and
more current, it's going to be really
interesting to see how hot the ESC's
get. I'm going to be using the AOS
Supernova 3220 for this testing because
at full throttle, this motor draws
upwards of 80 amps. And that is well
above the maximum continuous current
ratings of any of these ESC's. So, we're
going to really be able to see how hot
these ESDs start to get as we push them
closer and closer to their maximum
current rating. We're going to be
putting each of these ESC's through its
paces with three different tests. The
first is a responsiveness test where we
look at how fast the ESC can accelerate
and decelerate the AOS 3220 motor with
an HQ 10x5x3 test prop. Obviously, the
faster the ESC can accelerate and
decelerate the motor, the more
responsive a quad is going to be with
that ESC and the better flight
performance you're going to be able to
get. The second test is a torque test.
And here the ESC is going to drive the
AOS 3220 as it accelerates a large
flywheel from 0 to 10,000 RPM. This is a
good test of how well the ESC can
commutate the motor and how much of the
maximum torque the ESC is able to
extract. It's also a great durability
test because this is a really high burst
load and the ESC has to be able to deal
with that, deal with that huge rush of
current and still be able to commutate
the motor and accelerate the flywheel
effectively. The third test is the
thrust ramp torture test. Here we're
going to be very slowly ramping the ESC
throttle in steps of 10% from 10% all
the way to 100%. And while we do that,
we're going to be measuring the
temperature of the ESC with a thermal
camera. And that AOS Supernova 3220 is
going to be drawing more and more and
more current. And that ESC is going to
be getting hotter and hotter. We're
going to keep going until the ESC hits
150° centigrade on the FETSS, which is
way past overheat territory. And we're
going to see how much current the ESC is
able to supply, how much thrust it's
able to generate before it overheats.
And we're also going to be looking to
see how efficient the ESC is able to be
under these extreme conditions. Now that
we've looked at the test equipment
methodology, and the ESC's that we're
going to be looking at, it's time to
dive into the results. All of these
ESC's were tested with their factory
firmware, and the only settings change
was to adjust the KV in AM32 to match
the KV of the AOS Supernova 3220 that
we're using for the tests. Let's start
by looking at the acceleration
capability of the ESC's. And here we're
looking at the average of 20 identical
accelerations from 10% to 50% throttle
on my HQ 10x 5x3 test prop. All the
ESC's apart from one start off at pretty
much exactly the same RPM value around
2,000 RPM and accelerate up to about
9,000 RPM in just about 140 to 150
milliseconds. The one standout is the
T-OT Pacer 60 A V2 which starts off at a
lower RPM and that's because this is the
only ESC in this test that is running
BLHLY 32 firmware. The rest of the ESC's
are running AM32 firmware. In terms of
acceleration or sllew rate, the T-Mo F55
amp Pro 3 and the Pacer 60 A V2 are the
two fastest accelerating ESC's with the
Hummingbird 200 Racepec being the
slowest accelerating ESC. All of the
other ESC's fall somewhere in the
middle. Um, and they are all pretty
comparable apart from those two. So, now
let's take a look at the decelerations.
Here is the chart showing the average of
20 decelerations from 50% throttle to
10% throttle on my test prop. You can
see that all of the ESC's start off at
about 9,000 RPM and decelerate down to
about 2,000 RPM. Again, taking 140 150
milliseconds to get there. There is
again a bit of a difference in the final
RPM for the Pacer 60 A V2 because of its
different firmware. And the fastest
decelerating motors in terms of slooh
rate are the Hummingbird 305 and the
Pacer 60 A V2 ESC's. The slowest
decelerating ESC is the Hummingbird 200
racepec. And actually all of the other
ESC's are very very similar in maximum
deceleration to the Hummingbird 305.
There is not a massive difference
between all the ESC's in this
deceleration test.
Now, let's look at the results for the
flywheel torque test. And this test is
very similar to the acceleration test
that you just looked at. Again, we're
stepping from 10 to 50% throttle, but
this time, instead of accelerating a
test prop, we're accelerating a heavy
flywheel. So, we get to see just how
much torque the AOS Supernova 3220 is
able to develop when driven by each of
these different ESC's. Obviously, if the
ESC is commutating the motor more
effectively or delivering more current
to the motor, that's going to allow the
motor to develop more torque and
accelerate that flywheel faster. All of
the tests start off around 2,000 RPM
because obviously we're starting at the
same 10% throttle level and then
accelerate up to 10,000 RPM. The T-
Motor Pacer 60 A V2 has a clear
advantage in terms of peak torque,
delivering about 1.5 Newton meters of
torque at 3,500 RPM. And BLHLY32, which
is the firmware that this ESC is
running, clearly has a different shape
to the torque curve compared to AM32,
where the torque peaks much earlier
around 2,700
to maybe even 2,500 RPM. But the torque
peak is nowhere near as high as what we
get with BLHL32.
In terms of the AM32 ESC's, the F55 AMP
Pro 3 is doing the best in terms of
delivering the most torque and the
Hummingbird 200 race spec is struggling
a little bit and it's developing the
least torque. When the ESC is running
identical firmware, you can see that the
torque curves are pretty similar. The
main difference here is going to be the
ESC's ability to supply current to the
motor. Obviously, torque is proportional
to current. So, if the ESC can allow the
motor to draw more current because it's
got a lower resistance, then that is
going to allow the motor to develop more
torque and accelerate the flywheel
faster. Now, it's time to look at the
data from the torture test throttle
ramp. And there is loads of information
to go through here. We're going to start
with the efficiency of the ESC's. And
this efficiency is calculated as the
grams of thrust per watt of electrical
power delivered to the ESC. Each
throttle step was 10 seconds long and we
stepped up in steps of 10%. So 10
seconds at 10%, 10 seconds at 20%, 10
seconds at 30% and so on until the ESC
MOSFETs hit 150° and then the test was
stopped. You can see that there's a big
range of efficiency at lower throttle
settings. And it's a it's a big range. I
mean, we've got anywhere from about 4
1/2 g per watt up to about 7 1/2 g per
watt depending on the ESC. Obviously,
we're using the same motor and the same
prop in all of these tests. So, it just
goes to show how big a difference an ESC
can make. So, the efficiency of a
system, particularly at low throttle,
you can see that as the throttle setting
gets higher and higher, the efficiency
of all the ESC's tends to kind of
collapse down on top of each other. And
theoretically, we would expect the
efficiency of all the ESC's at 100% to
depend only on their resistance as the
FETSS are just going to be on all the
time. The T- Motor Pacer 60 amp V2 has
the lowest efficiency at low throttle,
but its efficiency improves as the
throttle setting increases. And you can
see that actually it's one of the most
efficient ESC's at the highest throttle
values. So that indicates that BLhell 32
isn't a super efficient firmware at low
throttles, but the actual construction
of the ESC, it's got a low resistance.
So at high throttles, its efficiency
improves relative to the other ESC's. If
we look at the AM32 ESC's, you can see
that they are all very, very similar in
terms of efficiency at low throttle,
which is what we would expect because
they're all running the same firmware
pretty much with the same settings.
When we get to higher throttle, we can
see that the T-mo F55 Amp Pro 3 is
slightly ahead of the other ESC's,
indicating that it's got a slightly
lower resistance. The most efficient ESC
at low throttles was the Hummingbird 200
racepec. But it should be noted that
this ESC became less efficient than the
others at higher throttle settings and
was one of the first ESC's to overheat.
It only reached about 70% throttle
before the ESC overheated and the FETSS
hit 150°. Now, we're going to look at
the temperature data from the ESC
torture test. And here, I recorded all
the ESC's with the thermal camera as we
stepped up in throttle from 10% to 100%,
stepping up every 10 seconds. And none
of the ESC's on this test made it all
the way to 100% throttle. They all hit
over 150 degrees centigrade on the
MOSFETs before we reached 100% throttle
for 10 seconds. And so this is a really
good test of how resilient the ESC is
going to be against overheating. We can
see how they compare, how hot they get.
Just to give you an idea of what this
data looks like, I've tiled and labeled
all of the thermal data in this clip.
You can see that all of the ESC's heat
up during the test. Initially, quite
gradually, and then much more quickly,
as of course, we're increasing to higher
and higher throttle levels. Once the
MOSFETs on each ESC hit 150°, I stop the
test. And then I can go back through all
of this thermal video to take
temperature measurements at particular
points. Initially, every 10 seconds, and
then much more frequently as the ESCs
get hotter and hotter. And that can give
us a temperature versus time chart. And
here is that temperature versus time
chart. Just to recap the test, we're
running 10-second throttle steps. So the
first 10 seconds is at 10% throttle. The
second 10 seconds is at 20% throttle.
The third 10 seconds is at 30% throttle.
And so on with the last 10 seconds being
at 100% throttle. So if the ESC makes it
to 100 seconds, that means it's run at
100% throttle for 10 seconds. And that's
the end of the test. Obviously, none of
the ESC's I tested made it all the way
to 100% throttle for 10 seconds, so they
all overheated at some point before
that. The T-Hobby Veloc 50 amp and the
new drone Hummingbird 200 race spec were
the first ESC's to overheat. And then we
had the new drone Hummingbird 305.
Then the Boret 80 amp mini, which is a
20x 20 ESC. Then the T-mo F55 amp Pro.
And then we had the Boret 80 amp, the
Velox 70 amp, and the T- Motor Pacer 60
amp all doing really well and making it
to 100% throttle for just a few seconds
before they completely overheated past
MOSFET temperatures of 150° centigrade.
Hopefully, this chart gives you a really
good idea of how robust each of these
ESCs are to overheating and therefore
how hard you can push them safely in
your quad. Looking at the results from
this test, one thing becomes startlingly
clear, and that is that the current
rating of the ESC is not a good
predictor of its resilience against
overheating. Some of the lower current
rated ESC's like the F55 amp Pro 3
outperformed some much higher rated
ESC's, some with ratings of 80 amps. So,
you can't just go off the current
rating. What does seem to be a better
predictor of resilience to overheating
is just the thickness of the PCB. The
ESC's with thicker PCBs all did a lot
better in this test. I think a thicker
PCB has more copper in it which reduces
resistance and it also provides more of
a heat sink to spread the heat from the
MOSFETs out and avoid the individual
FETSS getting to super high
temperatures. As well as a thick PCB, it
also seems to help to have an aluminium
heat spreader across the MOSFETs on one
side of the board. Again, I think that
just helps spread the heat out. And even
though I was always measuring from the
back side of the board where I could see
the FETSS themselves, having that
aluminium heat spreader on the other
side of the board did seem to provide
some additional robustness. So if you're
looking for an ESC that is going to be
the most resilient to overheating, the
most robust, then I would definitely
look for the thickest possible PCB and
the inclusion of an aluminium heat
spreader to spread the heat load out.
Now that we've been through all the
tests individually, it's time to bring
up the summary scores. And the way I
calculate these is by taking the
performance of each ESC on a particular
parameter, let's say acceleration, and
dividing that performance by the average
performance of all the ESC's on test. So
if an ESC has a score of 100%, it
performed pretty much average. If it's
got a score of 90%, it's 10% worse than
average. 110% is 10% better than
average. Then I take all of the scores
across the parameters and average them
and that gives me a total score which
isn't shown on this plot but the ESC's
are ordered by total score. So from
worst on the left to best on the right.
Hopefully this gives you an idea of how
the ESC's compare in performance to each
other on all the metrics. And we can see
that the best performing ESC is the
THobby Pacer 60 A V2. Although it does
underperform a little bit on efficiency,
um it is performing really well on all
of the other metrics and that brings its
total score up above all the other
ESC's. Second is the T- Hobby F55 Amp
Pro 3, which does really well across the
board. So, this is probably the kind of
allaround pick. And then we have the Bor
80 amp, the Veloc 70 amp. Um they're
doing really well for a 30x30 ESC. Then
we have a Hummingbird 305 from Newbie
Drone. The Bor 80 amp mini which is the
best performing 20 by 20 ESC I tested in
this batch. And then we've got the Velox
50 amp which um does pretty well across
the board apart from on the thermal
performance. It's just um using a
thinner PCB. It's designed for a lower
current so it overheats more quickly.
and the Hummingbird 200 race spec an
efficient ESC doing doing better in
efficiency but um struggling on the
other metrics. Hopefully with all of
this information this gives you an idea
of which ESC is going to be right for
your next build. Let me know down in the
comments what new ESC's or new tests
you'd like to see added for the next
batch of testing. And thank you for
watching until the end. That's all I
have for you for today. So until next
time, I wish you all very very happy
flying. Heat
[music]
up here.